I'd like to take a minute and
review some of the more
complex aspects of operators.
Let's start by taking a look
at some binary numbers.
Binary numbers are the crux
of bitwise operations.
And even though bitwise
operators are not commonly used,
they're good to know for those special
cases when you really need them.
I'll show you a good example of using
bitwise operators in just a moment.
Here at the top of this playground file,
I've defined the numbers 0
through 15 using binary literals.
Notice the 0B prefix before
each of these numbers.
On the right side of the playground
you can see how these binary numbers
are represented on our
normal base 10 system.
Below this, I've defined
the numbers 0 through 15 again, but
with the hexidecimal literals.
They're prefixed with the 0x.
You can see that there.
And again, the numbers are represented
in base 10 over to the right.
Now for each of these constants I've
declared them as the type UInt8.
An UInt8 type is similar to the Int type
except it restricts
the numbers from 0 to 255.
And we're doing this here just
to keep the numbers small.
What I mean by small is, is because it
takes so many binary digits to represent
a big base 10 number, we want to
keep those numbers really small so
that we don't have so much binary and
it just becomes really hard to look at.
Now, you can return to this
series of constants as a good
reminder of how we can count
using binary or hexadecimal,
and you can see how this
goes up by one each time.